all right uh it's superlatives time what
do you got well okay i mean i want to
talk about that game actually i don't
mean to always do this but i want to
give the don't forget about us award to
the ravens defense because that was the
story of the game even though we're
going to talk about lamar jackson and
how awesome he is and he still is
awesome i'm not trying to say anything
against that he's the mvp of football
right now clearly especially after
russell wilson last night but the ravens
defense yesterday was the story of that
football game again this is one of the
you know i think right now statistically
they're sixth in football and total
defense i would say they're one of the
five best defenses in the game they got
great size they got unbelievable corners
they got a defensive coordinator in wink
martindale who's very creative and i can
promise you the soros guy in the nfl
this morning is josh allen josh allen
got absolutely just his butt whooped and
obliterated and took so many hits in
that football game yesterday they could
not protect him at all kudos to him for
fighting through it but the ravens
defense i think was the story of the
game especially they set up some short
fields for the offense and uh and really
just made a number of big plays had the
strip sack fumble of josh allen that led
to a short scoring drive for the ravens
offense early on to get them up 10-00
but i thought that performance was
really special and then marcus peter's
cooling off with the beer bring it up
here come on it doesn't get any better
than that yeah and and that's the thing
the ravens are going to need their
offense and their defense you can't just
rely on one phase if you're going to go
as far in the playoffs as you'd like to
and and that's a look not easy to go to
buffalo and win this is a great bills
team and and they should not allow
themselves to get knocked wobbly by that
defeat they still could win they hung in
there
behind right the patriots but the ravens
just two wins away from being the one
seed in the afc they may not be playing
for anything week 17 against the
steelers other than possibly keeping the
steelers out of the playoffs which is
something which might be some of them
right steelers would be a bad matchup
for them all right my first award is the
it's not daniel or danielle it's
danielle hunter award because we got to
start getting the nate guys he's going
to his squad he's going to his vikings
now now
and when i say we i don't mean me i mean
you
you've mispronounced his name a few
times and i've never really called you
out now his whole life is the youngest
player in nfl history to get to 50 sacks
danielle it's danielle hunter okay henry
daniel and he is incredi and he is
standing still yes is intimidating
moving is extremely intimidating and
three sacks yesterday
just incredible what he can do when he
springs free and he told me after the
game because i said when do you know
it's going to be a good day for you said
i know the first couple plays i know
that if i can handle this guy or not i
know i know and and he was able to
handle uh the detroit lions and the
lions couldn't handle the vikings but
youngest ever to 50 sacks and
he never gets disgusted no he does not
never and he's really one of the best
edge defenders in the sport you're right
i mean he's very quiet yes and i've
talked to him several times over the
years he's starting to come out of a
little bit you know you can tell when
somebody is finally starting to realize
you know i'm pretty good at this right
so you start to be a little less
reserved he's kind of coming into his
own he's always deferred to everson
griffin but i think he's recognizing
he's starting to take over that defense
yeah it's his time and it's good he's he
seems like a great great kid he does kid
he's he's young he just turned 25 he is
a kid compared to me he's a kid yeah
well listen i'm at the age of 39 anybody
under 25 is a kid to me now too i don't
know where that happens where you become
an old man or you can call anybody a kid
when you're 39 yeah when you're 39. he's
a kid to me too but uh i'm with you does
not get the credit he deserves and
you're right probably because of some of
the other superstar names on that
defense that's kind of taken away from
what he's done but that's pretty special
uh 50 sacks shortest shortest ever right
the youngest ever
okay youngest ever all right um i'm
going with the uh lock stock and two
smoking barrels award to drew locke do
you ever seen that movie lock stock into
smoking barrels you need to see it's a
guy ritchie film very good you would
really like it it's called lock stock
and two smoking barrels yes it is it's
the prequel to snatch all right but
either way that i really drew luck is
who i want to talk about because drew
lock in two games uh has jump started
the denver broncos a little bit now last
week it was nothing special to
statistically through two touchdowns
early got them out in an early lead but
yesterday i mean you saw the talent the
guy had and that game in general that's
why i want to bring it up that was one
of the shockers of the day you know
there were so many other big games so
come on the houston texans just got
absolutely like
drubbed at home
against the the denver broncos where the
game was
to 3 at one point i mean are you kidding
me nobody saw that happening and drew
locke is the big reason he is phenomenal
and the reason i went with the two
smoking barrels because the two smoking
barrels are noah fan and cortland sutton
i mean they got a hell of a trio there
all right uh in denver for the future
and drew locke i think you see his
talent he's got a good pretty good
athlete you could see when the ball
comes off of his hand he has a pretty
special arm and they're more aggressive
in the passing game yesterday and he
brought a little life to this offense i
just want to give him some credit uh for
a big win on the road against the
houston texans yeah and according to our
friends at rotten tomatoes locked stock
in two smoking barrels is a grimy
twisted and funny twist on the tarantino
hip gangster formula
it's like that it is like 75 though i'm
not wasting two hours of my life unless
it's at least 90 percent friend i'm just
telling you it's worth that i'm not
wasting two hours of my life on your
recommendation okay fine the hell with
you then
uh lock stock and two smoking browsers
i've never even heard of it never heard
of it yeah i've heard of most movies
i've never heard of that it was the
movie before snatch and you know snatch
right no no with brad pitt snatch i
haven't seen it all right well look at
that i'll have to watch about this all
right uh next one for me co-worker of
the year award yeah does not go to baker
mayfield we look the the browns one it
feels like every time they win they
still have lost and all this odell
beckham jr stuff that's hovering over
the team is not useful and we've felt it
coming all week long over the weekend it
really erupted first with the
report from the cleveland plain dealer
that
that
odell beckham jr is being wasted in a
dysfunctional offense then the report
that he he needs hernia
surgery then jay glazer reporting that
he's told people beckham has with other
teams that he wants out wow and then it
all culminates in baker mayfield going
to the podium
and calling out the team's training
staff for how they handled the odell
beckham jr sports hernia and look on one
hand i look at and i say hey the players
get called out all the time when they
don't perform maybe others in a football
operation you hear me right but that's
not the way to do it no and baker
mayfield tried to backpedal it and and
look just once you cross that bridge
you've crossed that bridge yes and and
it's just
for all the and they won yes the last
two games they've won it feels like a
loss because there's always something
with this team they need to take a
complete and total top-down look at that
organization there is something
inherently dysfunctional in that
collection of players that they need to
get figured out because it's going to
keep them from being as good as they can
be but i and and it's just it's it's
unfortunate because we try to support
baker mayfield but you got to know what
you can and can't say and that is
something you cannot say you cannot call
those people out publicly he did it so
nonchalantly he said he was emotional
right in his tweet he didn't seem
emotional it was all very
very straight delivery very matter of
fact uh and and it's it's just it's it's
not good no no it's not good hey listen
they have some young could you imagine
how bill belichick would react well
enough
well that's what it doesn't happen and
that that to what you've said too that
starts with the head coach and him kind
of reigning guys in on the on the podium
when they are up there with a microphone
in front of their face too uh you know
baker mayfield i'll say this what he's
trying to do and there's better ways he
could have done it he's trying to stick
up for odell beckham jr which is where i
give him credit he's trying to let
everybody know that the guy's easy to do
though but you're right this guy's
played through a lot he's kept his mouth
shut he hasn't complained he's hurt
nobody really knew what it was there's a
way to do it without throwing people out
no doubt about it that's that's really
the point of it exactly right i his
intent i don't think was to throw
anybody under the bus i think he was
trying to stick up for you threw him
under the train yeah he threw him under
the train but he's trying to stick up
for his start player who you know is
important to him and he wants to have a
good relationship with him so uh but
yeah you got to be a little better there
all right the silent assassin ward a
silent assassination silent but deadly
assassin silent deadly his ryan
tannehill uh because i mean yes silent
but deadly he is silent he doesn't talk
a whole lot but his his play on the
field is doing a lot of talking i mean
ryan tannehill is playing some
unbelievable football and it was bombs
away yesterday against the oakland
raiders i mean hey don't look now but
the number one rated quarterback in
football by six points is ryan tannehill
i mean that's what's unbelievable and
i'm not all about in quarterback rating
and all that but it does tell you
something and tana hill the big thing to
me and like you saw yesterday when
there's a play to be had man does he
throw it and he could just it's it's
bullseye every time you know
specifically first and ten backed up
game seven seven people in his face bam
aj brown 50 something yards down the
field it ends up being a 95 yard
touchdown pass or 91 excuse me um but
him the way he throws the ball
aggressively down the field to me this
is i'm actually like the last few years
with the titans i've been like oh titans
please don't get in the playoffs you
guys are so boring you're you know you
maybe are going to win one game and ruin
the divisional weekend or something like
that i don't want to see it i'm actually
excited to see the titans this year
because of ryan tannehill because he's
consistent he he takes advantage of all
that's there to be had on a week-to-week
basis and therefore it makes them a
dangerous football team and that's why
they're on fire since he took over and
you called at the moment they pulled off
the trade with the dolphins to get ryan
tannehill that it's just a matter of
time before he supplies marcus mariota
if only they had done it sooner yeah
right right the guy's six and one as a
starter if they had realized earlier to
go with tannel instead of mariota they
wouldn't be fighting and scratching and
clawing for that last spot in the
playoffs because as it stands they need
the bills of the steelers to climb crazy
that's crazy they may not fit in yeah
they're going they've gone five and one
and they're not in but they still
control their playoff fate because they
got the texans twice right texans twice
wow and the texans are only
one game ahead right now yeah of or just
have a tiebreaker it's the same record
well but that's the thing if they beat
them twice yes right if they beat them
oh wait they do have the same record
yeah so yeah they beat them twice and
they're in they don't even have to they
don't even beat the saints now yeah so
don't look now but the titans are in the
thick of things and i like it and this
is a year that's the thing every other
year they've been in the playoffs are
like oh yeah oh this is a year i think
we kind of want to see him in i wouldn't
mind because i think if you're any of
these teams in the afc you don't want to
see that titan show up yes his his big
liability derek henry we know the
defense with dean pease and vrable are
going to be tough and have good game
plans what last one we got to give this
because this is the mds special
the end we had a triple d we had a
double triple yesterday austin eckler
austin eckler we got to give him the
double triple award i mean mds came up
with this stat it's awesome by him and
i'm like infatuated now i saw it i was
like oh gosh there's the mds double
triple so uh austin echoing austin 100
yards receiving 100 yards rushing as the
chargers destroyed the jaguars i'm
surprised that that
that everyone wasn't fired before they
went home last night after that when if
i'm shot con i'm beside myself now we
gotta take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports